voilà je voulais faire la liste des
expressions ou des trucs que les gens
font quand ils parlent qui m'énerve par
exemple dans la vie des fois il ya des
mecs quand tu les fais rire et insultes
c'est qu'on attends moi quand on me fait
rire je fais pas de fils de [ __ ] je te
baise
après il ya la phrase fantôme c'est à
dire c'est des mecs qui disent des mots
mais au final ils ont toujours rien dit
ouais non mais mais voilà après bon
d'accord mais personnellement c'est vrai
que bon voilà mais clairement way 0
idées exprimées après des foyers des
mecs quand on leur pose une question
ils répondent oui et non
j'ai pas par exemple plus leur demande
est ce que tu as aimé ce film alors oui
et non il faut choisir un avis soit tu
dis oui je te dis non imagine tu couches
avec une fille la capote à craquer
j'espère que t'as pas le sida alors oui
et non après j'aime pas trop les gens
qui après avoir vu un film sortait
d'expression ouais je trouve ça pas mal
mais la fin était un peu longuet y a que
quand on voit un film qu'on dit un peu
longuet à jamais par exemple un criminel
va dire j'ai fait quinze ans de taule
bon je te cache pas que j'ai trouvé ça
un peu longuet après il ya un truc c'est
le wpt est aspiré il ya des mecs quand
tu leur parles à quitter coûte il dise
le mot way en aspirant de l'air ouais
ouais
premièrement ça te donne un petit côté
secrétaire ou madame pipi créé
dégueulasse deuxièmement c'est bizarre
parce que c'est le seul mot qu'on peut
dire un aspirant jamais personne va
faire ouais et toi vous voyez aussi une
expression qui m'énerve c'est une
expression qui consiste à demander si
c'était une blague mais je suis parti de
chez moi j'ai complètement oublié de te
ramener son album de one direction
c'est une blague évidemment que ça pas
une blague
comme si on allait répondre ouais ouais
carrément c'est une blague
d'ailleurs c'est la vanne d'intro de mon
prochain one man show j'ai oublié ton cd
à la maison je pense qu'ils vont
vraiment rigoler c'est très très bien
trouvé bon après évidemment et aussi les
mecs un peu à l'ancienne qui au lieu
d'utiliser leurs propres mots préfèrent
utiliser des phrases préconçues un peu
ringarde sont comme je dis toujours
qu'il peut le mois le plus va savoir
aller
qu'à cela ne tienne ma foi c'est la vie
façon comme on dit bien manger c'est le
début du bonheur
alors ça c'est une pub non je me sens
bête dans le même genre il ya aussi les
mecs qui font un commentaire dès que tu
étais un as à tes souhaits watch a à d
amour a accusé mme bon j'ai la grippe
tu vas pas le dire toute la journée à
chaque fois après il ya aussi les
bilingue en anglais qui juste pour ça
paie t aime bien caser des petites
expression en faisant ce genre ils n'ont
pas fait exprès non mais cette histoire
m'a clairement pris la tête fabre
helliwell a bizarrement n'y a que les
bilingue en anglais qui font ça vous
n'allez jamais un mec qui fait non mais
cette histoire elle m'a pris la tête
avant car le problème est donc je disais
enfin je finirai par quatre expressions
qui me donne envie de donner des sorte
de claque virtuel aux mecs qui les
emploient il s'agit des mecs qui disent
bon pour le week-end prochain je sais
pas disons qu'on met une option là
dessus waouh c'est tellement sow 2012
wang qui me voilà c'est bien ce t-shirt
ou pas et mardi prochain c'est ma fête
et c'est aussi le jour de la sortie du
nouvel album de daft punk coïncidence je
ne pense pas fait mal quand j'ai vu que
vous étiez plus d'un 1,5 million à voir
cliquez ici pour vous abonner à ma
chaîne youtube simple et trop trop
plaisir donc vraiment un grand merci à
toutes et à tous pour ça quand je me
suis réveillé ce matin et que j'ai vu ça
j'ai fait waouh c'est une blague